[Music]
hello everyone
uh so in this uh
lecture we are going to go forward with
an
implementation of whatever we had been
discussing
uh in the previous lecture on the
example problem
illustrating uh
the airstress function now
i'll start a new file here
all right and now uh
almost the same things that i did
initially uh
while uh discussing the introduction to
jupiter notebook and
sempi i'll do it here also so first
things first
we import sempi as
we do a shift enter and it'll take some
time to
load up
done so we now define our two variables
x and y
that's done and now what we are going to
do
is to set up uh our edistress function
uh you please note that when we were
discussing the previous channel
you know when we were discussing the
previous
lecture
so here
i mentioned that a big challenge in this
edit stress function
is to choose a suitable air stress
function
okay so although we discussed various
things the boundary conditions and
everything here
but we we never really wrote down the
area stress function
because that is a real challenge uh what
to choose
so because we are not very sure what to
choose we'll choose
uh almost everything okay almost
everything mean
meaning that up to the fifth degree
polynomial if we choose then we can be
pretty sure okay so this is a very very
vague term pretty sure
but it has been seen that many problems
can be
addressed uh by choosing a polynomial up
to the fifth degree
so we'll take that of course uh for
certain problems you do have to take up
to 60
degree even but for now for this problem
uh we take up to the fifth degree
but unlike when we do it on a piece of
paper
we have to do a priority some kind of
clever thinking as to
what to drop and what not to drop which
terms to drop in which terms
not to drop here we'll make no such a
priority
uh decisions we'll take all the terms
that are present
uh starting from the second degree
to the cubic and the four degree terms
to the fifth degree okay so that will be
a
very very long area stress function to
begin with
okay and our hope is that by
using it by using the symbolic python
will be able to
systematize the whole thing and uh and
proceed
towards a very general kind of framework
to obtain the
stress fields okay so we do it in parts
here
uh so first of all the second degree
polynomial will have to
do a 2 0 x square
plus a 1 1
x into y plus a 0 2
into y 10 of course
these a 2 0 a 1 1 and a 0 2
they have absolutely no meaning
currently so we need to define them
first a 2 0 a 1 1
a 0 2 is equal to
just like we had done in the case of the
introductory videos
so that's it okay so
we can we can also display this thing
display this little bit
so that's our a distress function uh
considering only the quadratic terms our
plan is to similarly write down
air stress functions considering only
the cubic terms the quadrat and the the
four degree terms and the fifth degree
terms and then to consider
a a combined air stress function
considering all the terms
next for the cubic terms
a30 times x cube
plus a u1 times
xs squared times y
plus a 1 2 into x into
y square plus a 0
3 into y cube
we display that as well
next for the four degree terms we have a
four zero a
three one a two two a one three
a zero four
again we define these things a
4 0 e 3 1 e 2
2 a 1 3 a 0 4
now for the 8 4 we have a 4 0 into
x to the power 4 plus a 3 1
into x cube into y
plus a 2 2 into x
square into y square
plus a 1 3 into x into y
cube and finally is 0 4
into y to the power 4 again we display
this
and finally for the fifth degree
polynomial
we have a 5 0 whole one a
[Music]
0 four one eight three two
two three one four
uh so you can see that uh
i'd made a bit of a
mistake or so one would think by not
writing the underscore here
but it kind of symbolized and kind of
intelligently understood what was going
on what i really wanted
so that's good but nevertheless i want
to make this thing explicitly clear
please note that every time i do a shift
entering a cell the line
the input cell number it gets updated so
previously it was 5 is now become
7 anyway we'll proceed doing this in a
systematic fashion
finally the eight zero five and for the
85
i have a
five x zero the power 5
plus a whole 1 into x to the power 4
into y
plus a 3 2 into x to the x cube
into y square plus 8 2
3 into x square into y
cube plus a 1 4 to x into y
to the power 4 plus a 0 5
into y to the power 5
and we finally display the 825 as well
all right now all that we have to do
is to combine all of them into
uh a phi okay i might have as we'll call
that
as arie or rabbit or tiger doesn't
matter
and i just add them up okay 82 plus 83
plus 84 plus 85
and i display this
all right now
the first thing that i need to ensure is
that
this humongous eddy stress function that
i have written
what conditions must be satisfied so
that
the by harmonic equation
is not violated okay so we have to
understand that the by harmonic equation
so this phi must must satisfy
the bioharmonic equations what are the
conditions that must be satisfied
so for that we'll uh we'll consider the
bioharmonic of this let's call this as
the biohan will not define a separate
function uh unlike the
the introductory thing we'll just write
down this as an expression
so same dot def pi
uh x4
plus twice into sim dot f
by x x
y y so that will differentiate 5 with
respect to x
twice and with respect to y twice
and finally same dot diff
uh by
pi comma four right
so we can display this also
but more importantly because we really
want to
so let's first display this actually uh
okay now you see that there are some
brackets involved here
okay i don't want that so what i will do
is
i will i first of all expand this thing
okay just like in our introductory uh
things now those brackets are gone
it's all very nice and clear and
explicit now what i will do is
you see if i if i set this to zero
because that's that's
that's what the requirement is that the
by harmonic of 5
that should be equal to 0 now that can
be equal to 0
only if individually the coefficients of
x
the coefficients of y and all the
constant terms
they are zero so uh so let's let's see
if we can
do that so the
we'll need to set up three equations to
satisfy this so from this single
equation
okay or from this single expression set
equal to zero
we are going to obtain uh
three equations uh one from the
coefficient of x
one from the coefficient of y and one
from the constant terms
okay so uh let's
let's try to implement that uh first of
all
uh let's say we have the bioharmonic
uh coefficient of x so that will be by
harm
the coefficient x
the corresponding equation from this uh
let's call this
the condition one because that is the
first condition must that must be
satisfied
for our entire problem okay so
we set it up like an equation so by harm
x that should be equal to zero
in a similar fashion uh
we now have the bahama y
which is basically extracting the
coefficients
of y that will be set as condition 2
this will be another equation
and finally the byham let's call it by
ham 0
just to denote that these are the terms
which are the coefficients of
let's say x to the power 0 or y to the
power 0 that's what this
zero kind of signifies and that can be
done
by uh by the substitution
of of x
0 and y 0.
okay so what i'm basically doing here is
that
uh
so let me just do this thing and
directly let me just complete this
in a minute and then i'll show it to you
so let's display the three conditions
condition one
condition two and condition three
so uh
let me do a full screen here
okay so you see for the first condition
what i have obtained here
is this 24a14
24832 and this 120 a50
or from the condition of the
coefficients of y
set to 0 i'll have this 12805
24823 and this 24
a41 and finally for this one you see
in this equation when i wrote this line
i wrote the by harm zero comma zero
so the by harm zero here that is
the expression that i obtained when i
substitute
x equal to 0 and y equal to 0 in this by
harm expression
so if you set what x equal to 0 and y
equal to 0 this term is going to
disappear this one
this one this one this one and this one
so all that will be left
is this 24a04 from here
the 8822 and the 24a40
all right uh
and please note that those are actually
originating from the
fourth degree terms from the from the
are four
similarly the first and the second
conditions here they are originating
from the a5 so these are the first three
conditions that must be satisfied
for us to be able to solve this problem
and we are going to build up
more and more equations and conditions
as we go forward
so for that what we'll have to do is to
take the help
of the boundary conditions okay so let
us let us remind ourselves
uh from this from this previous
discussion
of these boundary conditions so you see
the boundary conditions are
all written down in terms of the
stresses the sigma yy the sigma xy the
sigma
xx all right now those boundary
conditions
are specified along the various edges
all right which means that when we have
to write down these conditions we have
to first of all
uh find the expressions the general
expressions of the
stress fields from the from the error
stress function that is from the phi in
our problem
and then subsequently we have to
substitute appropriately for the various
edges
at y equal to minus h or y equal to h uh
x equal to ax equal to minus a and then
proceed
okay so this is going to take a little
bit of time
but uh it's a very systematic way of uh
proceeding okay
so let's do this so first of all sigma x
x
so that will be same dot diff pi
y comma two okay
next sigma yy will be same dot div
by x comma two and sigma
x y should be equal to same dot tab
by x comma y
and let's not forget the minus sign
all right so if we display these things
you see we get these things all right
now
because we have been uh because we are
writing down a lot of expressions
and already we are in input cell number
12 things can get
out of hand pretty quickly so it might
be a good
point to start writing these things down
in a slightly more systematic fashion
uh using the ipython display kind of
style
so we'll do that now so from
my python dot display
import latex and now we are going to
display
uh our sigma xx sigma yy and sigma xy
um in a clearer fashion so display
produce a little bit of latex here
let me quickly write this down
so the first one was actually a sigma xx
all right
let's see if this thing works
uh sorry i should have done that
as format
that's better
similarly here sim dot latex
my x y all right
uh if we want
uh or perhaps it will be a good idea to
actually write these things down as
in their expanded notations okay because
you see that we have
a bracket here which might may cause a
trouble if we have to manipulate these
expressions
uh further so we want to have
nice expanded versions of this
the sigma xy is already in a full
expanded
uh notation so we don't have to worry
about it
uh we run that again so you see the
brackets are
gone similarly here we run this again
all right so now uh we can refer to
these expressions
as and when we need uh
so let us remind again ourselves what we
are doing here we have already found out
the three conditions
back here proceeding from the
requirement
that the early stress function that we
have chosen
by combining the the various degree
polynomials they must satisfy or that
must satisfy the by harmonic equation
next we are writing down the or we have
found out the expressions of the
stress fields with the intention of
of being able to write down the boundary
conditions as we have discussed
uh in the previous lecture all right
so for the boundary conditions what we
are going to do is we are going to take
up
the edges one by one okay so
it might not be a bad idea to to
maybe use the markdown facility
of writing a little bit of description
before you actually implement uh
implement those boundary conditions
through our symbolic python code here
so i'll do an escape and press m here to
change this cell to a markdown cell
and then light write a little
description above the boundary condition
that we are just going to implement
the first boundary condition is that y
is equal to minus
h so let us remind this that again so we
are going to implement this boundary
condition
that y is equal to minus h sigma yy is
equal to minus q naught
and sigma xy is equal to 0 okay
so first at
y is equal to minus h
boundary conditions are
sigma yy is equal to minus
q naught and
sigma x y is equal to zero
so
we need to do a sigma yy and substitute
y as minus h but
please note that till now we have uh we
have
neither defined h nor defined this q
naught
and that is going to create a problem
for us okay in fact you can do a shift
enter and it will already show an error
so see h is not defined so what we'll do
is
uh even before this cell
we are going to uh or perhaps before
this cell we are going to
define uh these uh these parameters
h and the load q okay uh we'll also take
uh we use also use that opportunity to
define the length
a which will also require okay so escape
and we press the letter a to in to
uh to insert a cell just above this cell
that's it so h
comma a is equal to same dot symbols
h comma a as easy as that however
we really want to be very sure of what
we are doing here
so that there is absolutely no trouble
later on and
since we know that both h and a are
like our length and they are supposed to
be positive
we can actually specify to symbolic
python that
these are positive quantities in this
using this syntax that positive is equal
to
similarly the q naught can be defined
in this fashion
and that also can be set as positive
equal to true okay it is not necessary
but
let's just do this
so i did the shift enter there another
shift entered and now it
understands what's going on now this is
only the expression of sigma yy where we
have substituted y equal to minus
h but we need to set this up as boundary
conditions all right
so what we'll do is we since this this
is an expression we don't want to keep
on writing the sigma yy dot subs
y comma minus h we'll call this
particular expression as p1
all right so uh
so now we can we can use this p1
expression
uh as part of our boundary condition
okay similarly we'll also have
d2 that will be sigma xy dot subs
y comma minus h
right so we can display this t1 and t2
but uh that's not necessary okay
uh what
what is more important to note here is
that if we just take a look at
uh all right let's let's uh
let's do this t1 and t2 just for
okay let me just discuss this you see
in this expression the first one which
is sigma yy
where the y has been substituted by
minus h
i have expressions which
are devoid of any x and y
but i do also have expressions which
involve x
which involve x square and which involve
x of q
similarly for this t 2 which is
basically sigma xy
substituted where y has been substituted
by minus h
i have expressions which are like
constants
i also have expressions which involve x
which involve
x square and which involve x cube
now consider consider the boundary
condition
sigma x y is equal to 0 which we have
written down here
now if sigma x y is supposed to be equal
to 0
then in because we have this kind of a
condition
where we also have expressions involving
x x square and x cube it must be true
that all the coefficients of
x cube must be individually zero all the
coefficients of x
square must be individually zero all the
coefficients of
x must be individually zero and all the
constant terms must be individually
zero that is very very important to note
in a similar fashion considering t1
we know that this t1 has to be equal to
minus of q naught
now because we have these various
terms in the t1 expression
which have x cube x square x as well as
the constant terms
and we have to set this equal to minus q
naught which happens to be a constant we
must ensure
that it is only the constant terms which
are equal to minus q naught
and the coefficient of x in this t 1
expression
that is those are equal to 0 the
coefficients of x
square those are equal to 0 and the
coefficients of x cube
those are equal to 0. this is a very
very important point
so we'll do that
immediately okay so
what we'll do here is uh
instead of displaying or let's keep that
for now okay
so we want to find out the coefficient
of x in this t1 expression
and we want to set that equal to zero
we set that up like a symbolic python
equation
and that mind you will be the
first part of our first boundary
condition
okay so please note here that this is
the first part of my first boundary
condition
next the second part of
the second part of my first boundary
condition that will be
the coefficient of x square
at equal to zero
the third part of my first boundary
condition
will be the coefficient of
x cube at equal to
zero and
the final one the fourth part of my
boundary condition uh
my my first boundary condition
will be where
i substitute x as 0 because you note
that in this first expression if i
substitute x equal to 0
all that will be left is just this
constant terms
and i do want that constant terms to be
equal to
minus of q naught that's it
okay so these are the four parts of my
first boundary condition
and i can actually display them also
so you see previously i had these three
conditions
generated from the requirement of
satisfying the boundary conditions
those three equations are now added four
more
conditions based on the
first mathematical boundary condition
that sigma yy
is equal to minus q naught at y equal to
minus h
so these four four equations that we are
obtaining
those correspond to the the uh to the
actual
mathematical boundary condition which we
had written uh
in our in this previous lecture so this
is
this is what we have just implemented
sigma yy is equal to minus q naught
and we have a long way to go before we
can finish up with the rest but we'll do
that
next for t2 for t2
we'll have so let's and we are using
these kinds of boundary conditions
uh nomenclature bc1 bc2 b60 bc4 will
continue in that
same vein so here again
e2
coefficient of x that must be set equal
to zero
and let me just quicken things up a
little bit
by using copy paste
again coefficient of x square set to
zero
next coefficient of x cube set to zero
that will be the third part of my second
boundary condition
and finally all the constant terms here
a must be set to zero okay because you
note
that uh if you just take a quick look
here the sigma xy is equal to equal to
zero
unlike the sigma yy which had a non-zero
value
so all the constant terms present in
this sigma xy expression
that is also equal to 0 that's what we
have just implemented in this bc8
and will again display this pc5 to bc8
uh sorry
i should have written that as a dot
all right
next we are going to take up uh
the boundary condition at y equal to
uh plus h
this one okay and now this you see that
sigma yy is equal to zero
as well as sigma xy is equal to zero so
this is uh
going to be written on very easily
uh we can actually uh
so first of all you note that till now
we have not actually written down the
the the
expressions where sigma yy
in sigma yy we have substituted y is
equal to h
so here in both in t1 and t2 we have
only substituted y equal to minus h that
was for the
you know for for the top edge for the
bottom edge where y is equal to a
h we have to separately write down write
this down as t3 and t4
so t3 will be sigma yy your sub
sub y comma h and t4
will be equal to sigma xy
dot subs y comma h and again we can
uh display these things just like before
we don't have to
but just to see
okay all right so again we proceed with
the
writing of the various parts of the
boundary conditions
we had stopped previously at bc8 so the
next is bc9
so same dot equation uh
so this time we need to use t3 and
now coefficient of x because you see
here in this t3 expression again we have
coefficients of
x coefficient of coefficients of x
square and coefficients of x cube
so we'll do that part by part okay so
this must be set equal to zero
similarly for the coefficients of x
square
pc ten
dc 11
coefficient of x cube
finally for bc 12 we'll have to
substitute
in the expression of t3
x as 0 so that we can extract all the
constant terms and again we display this
that's it we have four more conditions
now so see how we are building up
the various conditions that will require
in order to finally solve
uh for for these coefficients uh
these unknown coefficients uh a with the
various subscripts
next we take up t4 uh
so we can just copy paste from here
make things even faster but you have to
be really careful
with not proofing up these numbers
so first of all all of these must be d4
this is pc 13 14 15
16
all right
next uh we have to consider the two
vertical
edges so let's take a quick look at
the vertical edge x equal to a so here
we have three conditions three boundary
conditions
uh the axial force one the bending
moment one
and the shear force one okay
so we are going to implement them one by
one
so again we require the required to
substitute in the expression of sigma xx
uh x equal to a similarly for sigma
xy so let's do that first
we have reached up to e4
in the previous expressions and we need
to call this as t5
sigma xx for subs x comma
a and t
6 is equal to sigma xy dot subs
x comma a all right so e5
is for sigma xx at the right vertical
edge
and t6 is for sigma xy and the right
vertical edge
uh let's display this also
and now you see that when we have
substituted
after we have substituted x equal to a
in uh in the
expressions of sigma xx and sigma xy in
the
in the expressions that we obtained we
are left with terms
which involve the y the y squared
uh and also the y cube okay in both of
these we have
the coefficients of y y square and y
cube
in addition to the constant terms so
just like before
what we are going to do is when we set
this t5
is equal to zero we have to set
separately
the coefficients of y y square y cube
as well as the constant terms by setting
y equal to zero
all right so that's what we'll do
sequentially
so uh
so if we do that okay what i just said
if i if we do that then i will end up
with
with just so if we do exactly like this
okay what i had just mentioned
then we'll end up with conditions
which will not be like this
because you see this uh integration
sigma x x d y equal to 0
it does not necessarily mean that sigma
x
x is point y 0 all over from y equal to
minus h to y equal to h
so i do not want to uh to be
to actually set the individual terms of
the sigma
xx to be equal to 0 or the coefficients
of y y square and all those things to be
equal to 0
rather i first want to obtain this
integration
and then set this integration equal to
zero so if i do like before
it will be wrong okay now it will not be
a property so if i do like this
okay coefficient where instead of this
coefficients of x x square and x cube i
write coefficients of y y square and y
cube uh
from from this t5 and then set those to
zero
it will not be a proper implementation
of the uh the boundary conditions that
we have written down
rather i have to first do the
integration for that i do
uh sim dot integrate
and this is e5
this has to be integrated uh
over y as y goes from minus
h to h so that is written down as y
minus h to h
and we must also make sure so let's just
let's just display this
so you see this is quite a complicated
looking
expression but thankfully there are no
terms involving the y y square and y
cube of course not because we have
already done the integration with
respect to y
but this is not in a very nice easy to
handle a fashion i mean notation
so we need to expand this also
so now this is nicely set up and what
we'll do is we'll set
this entire integration to be equal to f
of
fx1 so this fx1 basically
denotes that this is like the axial
force in the x direction
and we'll also have f x 2 for x equal to
minus a so we'll do that later
okay but
[Music]
now uh we also need the
a corresponding expression for the
bending moment
okay so what i mean to say is that i
need to implement this
integration also sigma x x times y d y
so not a problem you can do this
just like this so for the bending moment
we have
m is equal to uh and again i'm going to
do a
expand write that down beforehand
m dot integrate uh
e5 okay so the t5 is basically the sigma
xx expression
where x has been substituted as a
but now i have to multiply this this
expression with
y and then carry out the integration
just like i had done before
from minus h to h okay so lots of
brackets here
uh but since we are working from the
inside out they should be correct
all right and now we display this thing
i mean it will get displayed
automatically
uh sorry so in the previous step
it is f of x1 and here also i need to
display this
m1 okay now it's
where i want it to be and let us not
forget the sigma
xy so that sigma xy substituted
so where the x has been substituted by a
that is stored in t6
and what we have to do in order to
implement this boundary condition
the at x equal to a sigma x y
integration minus h to h d y
uh is equal to minus q naught a ah
we proceed in a similar fashion we call
this v one
again expand we write this beforehand so
there is no
problem later on and then sim dot
integrate
uh e6
integration of integration from minus h2
h integration with respect to y from
minus h to h
and we can display this also
okay all of this is fine but we have not
yet actually written down the boundary
conditions
so the last boundary condition that we
wrote the bc equation that we wrote
back here was for uh
let's see
you see there's a little bit of a
mistake that is present here
i had not noticed it earlier but
thankfully i have scrolled up now
so this is bc 13 14 16. it's not a
mathematical mistake i was just
displaying this but anyway we don't want
to be doing wrong things
uh even if they do not matter
okay so what we have done is not
mathematically incorrect we have just
we just displayed this wrongly okay now
it's all right
uh now the point was that the last thing
that we had written there was bc16
so now we have to start from bc uh 17
okay so bc 17 will correspond to this
the fx one so same dot
equation f x one
that fx 1 is equal to 0
bc 18 will be same dot equation
m1 that will be equal to 0
and bc 19 we take a look once more
uh and what should be the expression for
this v1
uh this this thing so sigma xy dy so
that is the v1 that is equal to minus q
naught
a at x equal to so we write that down
here properly
minus q naught into a all right
we display this bc70 bc
18 bc 19
all right so we have three more
equations okay we are going to have
many many equations all right so the
last
edge is the left vertical edge at x
equal to minus a
and quickly take a look at that so the
first two conditions are exactly like
at x equal to a and the third one
is just having a q naught a instead of a
minus q naught a
all right so what we are going to do
here
is
we can copy paste from here
but you have to be careful with the
numbers that we write down otherwise
it's going to be horrible mess
so we start from t7
and d8 so sigma x6 now has to be
substituted
with x equal to minus a similarly for
sigma x y
and now we want to display this as h7
and d8
and just like we had done for this
f of uh fx1
m1 and v1 we are going to do a fx2 m2
and v2
so this is f x2
is going to be d7
similarly for our bending moment
we can copy the expression from here
being careful to change the numbers
this is my m2 and we display this m2
all right and finally for the v2 we copy
from the v1
but make sure that we change the t6 to
p8
all right so
as
for the boundary conditions as before we
have to use
use these things
making sure to change the numbers so we
start from dc
20. 21
22 and these are fx
2 and 2 and v2
and note that we change this to plus of
q naught a
okay again we remind ourselves that the
v to this integration of sigma x y
at x equal to minus a integration of
minus h to integration
with respect to y from minus h to h that
is equal to plus q naught a
unlike what was at x equal to a all
right
that is what we have just implemented
here and here we
accordingly display this uh bc 2021 and
22.
all right so you see we have uh
quite a long list of equations we have
three here
okay so as you can see this is bc 22
already
and in addition to these 22 equations we
also had those three conditions at the
very beginning
okay so these three conditions
so our job now is to solve this
three plus 22 equal to 25 equations
simultaneously
okay so remember when we did that little
toy example
in our introductory discussion uh with
linsolf
uh we'll exactly do that here
okay now uh
there is a little bit of an issue here
uh
but but uh but we'll see okay we'll
discuss that
uh once you have uh once we are done
with this thing
okay so uh so we are at the stage where
we have in our hand
uh 25 linear simultaneous equations
uh involving the various coefficients a
with the various subscripts
and we have to solve these 25 equations
to obtain these
values okay in terms of
uh of the given parameters u naught
a and h that's it that's our job
okay the entire problem has reduced to
this used to solving this linear
simultaneous
equations okay so
the way we go about doing it is to use
the lin solver
okay so
now this is going to be a little bit
tedious to write but
we'll do this
bc one bc two bc three pc
four five
six seven eight
nine
10 11
i hope you don't fall asleep
in 19 bc 20 bc 21 and bc 22
so let me just make sure that i have
written all of them 22 21 20 19 18 17 16
15 14 13 12
11 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1
and the three conditions so all over all
i have
these 25 equations
now i need to write down what i'm
actually solving for
okay so what i'm solving for are the
various coefficients in the quadratic
polynomial terms in the cubic polynomial
terms
in the uh in the four degree polynomial
terms and the fifty degree polynomial
terms
so this is basically a two zero a one
one
is zero two so ad2 is done
a three zero a two one a
one two a zero three cubic is done
a four zero a three one a two
two a one three a
zero four four degree is done a
five zero
[Music]
all right so that's it
uh the moment of truth so whether it can
solve it or not
uh sometimes there are some issues uh
but
but let's just let's just try to
implement this okay so shift
enter
and what do you know we have a solution
here all right
so uh
so you see uh the way that we have
written down here it'll it'll be a
little bit
difficult to try because you have so
many things now we've solved for
uh many of these are turning out to be
zero
uh as you can almost expect uh
because if you just go back to these
equations that you have written
uh you'll see that some of them are
identically zero
okay for example this a41 okay so that
is zero
uh you go back a little bit more you'll
see this a five zero
is also equal to zero and if you had
solved by hand you would have seen like
how many of them i mean it comes out so
simply but
overall uh we have managed to do it in a
couple of seconds like
once we have written this down it was
quite tedious to write down but
uh no big brain work involved really we
just had to type it carefully
and the moment we press shift enter i
mean
okay after a weight of about two three
seconds we got the answer
uh now we can go ahead
and uh and write this down in a very
uh in a very nice and clean fashion
using the ipython display style
but you please note that
our our main job here uh
is actually done okay so the unknown
coefficients of the edit stress function
that we have in our hand
okay answer is here in our hand and
because we now know
the expression of pi courtesy the
knowledge of
these various values of the of the of
the
a terms or the a coefficients uh we can
go ahead
and write down the expressions of sigma
xx
sigma yy and sigma xy okay and those
expressions would be true
all throughout the domain of the beam
okay and this is
uh so i i hope uh
if you try to solve this same problem
by hand the first challenge would be
that there is no way you can i mean
you can proceed of course i mean you can
be infinitely patient and
trying to do this kind of a thing but
nobody does it like that you
take only limited number of terms play
around
do a hidden trial uh see which terms you
could probably wisely
delete and then proceed uh
or if you really want to implement this
solution
well good luck now the issue that i
really wanted to point out
okay so i'm not really continuing here
with the rest of
the trivial steps which will actually
give us i mean explicitly the
expressions of sigma x x sigma yy and
sigma xy
that can be very well done but what i
really want to highlight here is that
uh i mean one very good power or
facility that symbolic python allows you
you please take a quick look at the
at the coefficients that we have solved
here you see how many of them are here
1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9
10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18.
so we have solved for this 18 unknown
coefficients of
a with the various subscripts and how
many equations did we provide
we had provided this bc 1 to 22
plus 3 conditions so in total 25
conditions
okay so we are linear we are solving 25
linear simultaneous equations
which are not actually independent so
it's an over determined system
but even then symbolic python has very
nicely given us the solution
so we are solving for 18 uh unknown
things
from 25 equations so of course it's an
over determined system
uh but still we are getting a nice
solution out of it okay
so this is uh another great facility
that symbolic python
allows us all right so with this i will
end this
rather long discussion
but i hope that uh in other problems
also
you can use the same kind of framework
with little bit of changes here and
there
uh careful changes of course uh to
implement the solution
okay all right so i hope this is really
useful to you
thank you very much